In today’s video we are covering our first
Saint worshipped both by the Catholic and
Eastern Orthodox churches, revered for having
first introduced Christianity amongst the
Rus.
These were a pagan people of Nordic descent,
who ruled over a vast land in the early Middle
Ages, from the Baltic to the Black Sea.
But her holy title should not fool you, as
she did not dedicate her life solely to prayer
and converting the heathen.
This Saint was a ruler, the regent of the
Principality of Kiev, and one of the most
powerful women of the early Middle Ages.
Most of her life is lost to the shadows of
history, while the rest has emerged from the
mists of legend.
In today’s Biographics, we will learn how
this widow of a Prince, with an infant son,
defended her throne against insidious suitors,
hostile tribes and invading nomadic raiders.
Most of all, we will hear about the incredible
story of how she avenged her husband with
acts of escalating, ruthless cunning.
Please welcome today’s protagonist, Princess
Olga of Kiev.
The Kievan Rus
Before I begin the story of how Princess Olga
defended her family and her lands, allow me
to give you some context.
Who were the Rus people and what lands did
they rule over?
The Rus, sometimes also called Varangians,
were people of Scandinavian ethnicity who
had founded the ‘Kievan Rus’ -- a political
federation that lasted from 862 to 1242.
This state was located in modern-day Belarus,
Ukraine, and western Russia, which is actually
named after the Rus.
The capital city of this federation was Kiev,
in modern-day Ukraine.
`Kievan Rus’ can simply be translated as
“the lands of the Rus of Kiev”.
Their Scandinavian origin was first mentioned
by a Byzantine diplomat (and eventual Saint)
named Bertin, who first recorded their presence
in his Annals of 839.
But most of the stories about the origin of
the Rus comes from the Primary Chronicle,
known also as the Tale of Bygone Years, an
early Russian text from the 12th Century.
According to the Chronicle, the original dwellers
of the area in the mid-ninth century had invited
the Rus – described also as Vikings – to
rule and maintain order in their country.
One of these Vikings was called Rurik, and
he founded his own dynasty, which ruled over
the area for more than seven centuries.
The first Tsar of Russia -- Ivan IV, or Ivan
The Terrible -- was a direct descendant of
Rurik’s.
The Kievan Rus, however, had ceased to exist
as a political entity long before Ivan.
Between 1237 and 1242, the federation was
overrun by the unimpeded advance of the Mongol
hordes!
The federation was divided into smaller, disjointed
countries, which eventually evolved into Ukraine,
Belarus and Russia.
But now, back to Rurik, as his bloodline is
directly involved in our main story today.
At an unspecified time, in the second half
of the 9th Century, Rurik had established
his capital in Novgorod, and his men had begun
raiding the surrounding area, in true Viking
style, even going as far as attacking Constantinople.
When Rurik died of natural causes, his first-born
son Igor was too young to rule, and was put
under the care of Oleg of Novgorod.
After more campaigns to conquer and consolidate
territories around Novgorod, Oleg moved the
capital to Kiev, to seize the enormous wealth
amassed by two former allies of Rurik.
In 912, Oleg died, and in a very interesting
way, too.
A prophecy had foretold him that his favourite
horse would be the cause of his death.
Oleg, a superstitious man, had made sure the
horse was cared for as far as possible away
from him.
When he heard that the horse had died, Oleg
considered himself freed of the curse, and
mockingly kicked at the poor animal’s skull.
He chose poorly: a snake beneath the carcass
was startled, bit Oleg on the foot, and killed
him.
In the meantime, Igor had come of age, and
so he ascended to the throne, formally becoming
Prince Igor of Kiev.
By this time, he had already married a Varangian
Lady named Olga.
The Slaying of a Prince
Following in the footsteps of his father and
his guardian, Igor continued engaging in successful
conquests, raiding the neighbouring territories
and exacting heavy tributes to fill his coffers.
But Igor was greedy, and he wanted more.
In 945, he considered paying a visit to the
land of the Drevlians, a local tribe which
had been an ally to Rurik, joining his raiders
in attacks against the Byzantine Empire.
Later, the Drevlians had paid tribute to Oleg,
but had stopped when he had kicked the horse’s
head.
Since then, the Drevlians had paid what was
effectively protection money to a rival landlord.
Igor saw this as a perfect occasion to collect
some late payments and set off on his mission.
According to the Primary Chronicle, he raided
the land of Dereva and collected his tribute
by violence.
But on his way back to Kiev, he still felt
a thirst for more gold and riches.
He ordered his men to return home, except
for a few followers.
With them in tow, he rode back to the Drevlians
“desirous of still greater booty.”
Like Oleg, he had tried his luck once too
many.
His returning party was spotted by the Drevlians,
who reported back to their leader, Prince
Mal.
The Prince had had enough, proclaiming,
"If a wolf come among the sheep, he will take
away the whole flock one by one, unless he
be killed.
If we do not thus kill him now, he will destroy
us all."
The Drevlian warriors then rode forth from
their city of Iskorosten, massacred Igor’s
soldiers and reserved for him a gruesome execution.
I will leave the description to Byzantine
chronicler Leo the Deacon:
“They had bent down two birch trees to the
prince’s feet and tied them to his legs.”
And then:
“They let the trees straighten again, thus
tearing the prince’s body apart.”
With this threat disposed of, the Drevlians
planned their counterattack.
They would take over Kiev itself, not by conquest,
but by marriage.
Prince Mal ordered for some emissaries to
visit the now widowed Olga to ask for her
hand in marriage.
It is not clear if this was a common habit
at the time, or if Mal was simply very arrogant.
Back in her capital, Olga awaited for Igor’s
return in vain.
By her side, she had her boy son Svyatoslav,
who too young to fight, let alone rule.
Mal’s idea was that by becoming his stepfather,
he could influence the little prince into
doing his own bidding.
So the delegation of the Drevlians sailed
a boat along the river Dnipro.
Mal had sent twenty of his best advisors to
put forward his proposal, clearly believing
they would be welcomed with open arms.
This is when the Primary Chronicle, and our
own story, centres on Olga.
The Princess sent her own emissaries to ask
for the reason of the Drevlians’ visit.
They announced that they had slain her husband,
because
“He was like a wolf, crafty and ravening”
but that Prince Mal was a good leader and
that Olga should come to the land of Dereva
and marry him.
Olga’s reply was what the delegation was
expected.
In fact, she said that their proposal was
pleasing to her ears, but asked for the delegates
to wait on their boat, and that they would
be picked up the following morning.
As the twenty Drevlians waited, Olga had the
hall of her castle prepared to give them their
deserved welcome.
The morning after, when the Rus came to collect
the Drevlians, the latter demanded to be carried
into the castle in their own boat.
The Rus complied, as this was the same order
they had received from Olga.
When they arrived in the castle, they found
what surprise lay waiting for them: during
the night, the Princess had commanded for
a large, deep ditch to be dug within the castle
walls.
The Drevlians did not have time to react,
as the Rus hurled them, boat and all, inside
the trench.
The delegates protested to no avail, as Olga
ordered that they be buried alive.
With her simple trap, the Princess had wiped
out a large part of the enemy leadership.
That was only the beginning of her revenge.
A Feast of Mead
Prince Mal was unaware of what had happened
in Kiev, so he was not suspicious of the message
he received from Olga.
She insisted that she was eager to meet, but
she would do so only if Mal sent more of his
own distinguished men to pick her up.
The Prince, who it is safe to say, was quite
a gullible man, agreed to it, and gathered
more of his chieftains, warriors, and advisors
to pay homage to the Rus Princess.
When this second delegation arrived in Kiev,
Olga demanded that they bathe before she would
give them audience.
The Drevlians, surely tired, sweaty and covered
in dirt from the journey, eagerly complied
and entered the bathhouse that had been readied.
As they relaxed inside the sauna, they were
startled by a sharp noise: somebody was locking
the bathhouse doors from outside.
Their attempts to force their way out were
futile.
In horror, they heard Olga’s stern voice
through the wooden doors.
She had just given orders to set the house
on fire.
First by earth, then by fire, the Princess
regent had sealed her first two murderous
campaigns against the enemy tribe, with their
leadership almost entirely decapitated.
But she wasn’t done yet.
Before Mal could become suspicious of the
long absence of his men, she sent another
message:
"I am now coming to you, so prepare great
quantities of mead in the city where you killed
my husband, that I may weep over his grave
and hold a funeral feast for him."
Mead was a popular alcoholic beverage in medieval
times, made with fermented honey and water.
When they received the message, the Drevlians
set to work, preparing gallons of mead and
a lavish feast.
Olga arrived shortly thereafter, with a small
escort in tow.
She arrived at Igor’s tomb and asked her
men to build a funeral mound, around which
the Drevlians gathered for the funeral feast.
Some Drevlian who was smarter than the others
asked what had become of the two delegations
they had already sent, to which the sly Olga
replied that they were on their way, escorted
by her late husband’s guard of honour.
With the Drevlian judgment clouded by the
rivers of freely flowing mead, they swallowed
the lie easily.
Olga asked her men to wait upon the Drevlians,
ensuring their cups were never empty.
She waited patiently until they were all drunk
and at her signal, the massacre started.
Taken by surprise, her enemies fell one by
one under the blades of the Rus.
According to the Chronicle, five thousand
Drevlians were cut down at the Red Funeral.
Revenge Is a Dish Best Served on Fire
A five-thousand man massacre still was not
quite enough.
Olga was bent on complete, total reprisal.
Again moving swiftly, the Princess returned
to Kiev and gathered her army.
The boy Prince Svyatoslav joined his mother,
and together, they marched back to the land
of Dereva.
He was just a child, but when his troops made
contact with the enemy, Svyatoslav was the
first to cast a spear from atop his horse.
His arms were obviously too weak, and the
spear barely cleared the horse's ears.
Regardless, Olga’s Generals, Sveinald and
Asmund, proudly announced that the prince
had already begun battle, and pressed the
vassals to follow his example.
The Rus charged forward and completely routed
the Drevlians.
The surviving men, women and children of the
unfortunate tribe sought refuge within the
walls of their main city, Iskorosten.
Olga and her troops besieged the city, but
the Drevlians valiantly repelled their assaults.
They knew that this was a fight for their
own existence and would resist to the bitter
end.
In the meanwhile, other towns and cities of
their land had capitulated, and were now living
in relative peace with the Rus.
They were of course, paying their tribute!
After one year, Iskorosten still stood firm,
and Olga had to think of another plan to resolve
the stalemate.
One day, the besieged citizens received a
message from the Princess:
"Why do you persist in holding out?
All your cities have surrendered to me and
submitted to tribute, so that the inhabitants
now cultivate their fields and lands in peace.
But you had rather die of hunger, without
submitting to tribute."
The Derevlians started to buckle and replied
that they would be glad to pay tribute, but
that they could not trust her, as she was
still determined to avenge Igor.
Olga was apparently relieved to start negotiations
with the defenders and let them know that
she considered her slain husband to have been
already avenged, not once, not twice, but
thrice.
After all, she had already massacred two delegations,
plus those who had attended the funeral feast.
In order to seal the peace, she demanded one
last, small tribute from the Drevlians, after
which she would return home.
Olga’s request was surprisingly modest,
as she realised that the city had been impoverished
by the siege: she only wanted three sparrows
and three pigeons from each house.
The Drevlians were elated.
They collected the small flocks of six birds
from every household and sent them to Olga,
who promised to lift the siege the following
morning.
This was the last act of Olga’s plan of
total revenge and annihilation.
If one year of frontal assaults and siege
engines could not achieve victory, the intellect
of a Princess definitely could.
And she would so by turning innocent, harmless,
pet birds into a weapon of mass destruction.
She ordered her soldiers to take one bird
each and to attach to their talons a piece
of sulphur, bound in cloth.
When night fell, the soldiers released the
sparrows, and the pigeons.
Their silent wings carried them back to their
nests, their dove-cotes, under the eaves of
their homes.
One by one, the houses of Iskorosten were
lit by fires.
Soon, the whole city was burning, its inhabitants
either killed in their sleep or running in
terror, unable to extinguish the flames.
Some of them fled outside the city walls,
but they were quickly seized by Olga’s soldiers.
She kept the elders captive, had some of the
others sold as slave, and many more were killed
on the spot.
This was the final and total triumph of Princess
Olga of Kiev, victor of Iskorosten, scourge
of the Drevlians, Mother of Sparrows.
[Note to the Team: I liked the idea of giving
her a string of titles like another vengeful
Queen of a popular series of books and TV
shows.
Victor of Iskorosten is quite logical.
Scourge of the Drevlians I heard it on a podcast
about her revenge story, but it did not have
source.
But again, difficult to argue with.
Mother of Sparrows, is a title I gave her
myself, which I think sounds good and ties
back to that other Queen, who despite her
dragons wasn’t half as effective]
A New Faith
In the following years, until 948, Olga continued
to act as regent for her boy prince Vyaroslav.
The Drevlians had been completely subdued
and paid regular tribute to the Rus.
The Principality was at peace and grew prosperous.
Finally, the Princess set on a journey to
Constantinople, or as the Rus called it, Tasr’grad,
the City of Caesars.
The Chronicle does not offer a reason for
this visit, but we can assume it was of a
diplomatic nature.
The Rus and the Byzantine Empire had a love-hate
relationship, characterised by raids and attacks
by both sides, but also by trade and occasional
cooperation.
It was during this period that Byzantine Emperors
actually started to recruit Rus warriors in
their elite Varangian guard.
In 948, the Emperor was Constantine VII, who
upon meeting Olga, immediately took a liking
to her.
Impressed by her beauty and intellect, Constantine
remarked that she was worthy to reign with
him.
We have learned by now that Olga did not take
well to suitors, but in this case, her reaction
was… well, less violent, at least.
The Princess did not outright reject the proposal,
but simply stated that being a pagan, she
could not marry a Christian monarch.
But, if he really insisted, he could baptize
her.
The Emperor agreed, and with the assistance
of the Patriarch of Constantinople, had her
converted into the Christian Orthodox faith.
The Chronicle reports that Olga accepted very
eagerly the teachings of the Church
“like a sponge absorbing water.”
At her baptism, she was christened Helena,
and the Emperor acted as her godfather at
her own insistence.
-
After receiving the sacrament, Olga, or Helena,
was summoned by Constantine who renewed his
proposal.
There were no obstacles now; she should become
his wife!
But she replied that this was not possible.
He was her godfather, after all, which made
her his daughter in the eye of the church.
It was unlawful for a man to marry his own
daughter!
The Emperor considered her reply, then simply
said
"Olga, you have outwitted me."
He then covered her in gifts, gold, silver,
and silks, and bade her farewell.
Olga had barely returned to Kiev when she
received a message from the Emperor.
Apparently, those gifts were not entirely
for free and he expected slaves, wax, furs
and mercenaries in return.
What a cheapo.
Olga was unfazed and simply replied to the
Byzantine envoy that she would pay back her
due only if the Caesar was willing to spend
as much time in Kiev as she had spent in Constantinople.
It is not recorded whether the Emperor paid
her a visit, so we will assume he didn’t
… and she had outwitted him again!
Now, as a recently converted Christian, Olga
tried to spread her new-found religion amongst
her people, starting with her own son.
But Prince Svyatoslav was not convinced, fearing
he would be mocked by his subjects if he did
so.
Olga accepted this refusal as her only defeat
so far, but according to the Chronicle, she
prayed day and night for God to forgive the
heathen souls of Svyatoslav and the Rus.
By 956 Prince Svyatoslav had come of age,
and, hungry for conquest, he built a valiant
army and set off on several lengthy campaigns
away from Kiev.
While he was away, the land of the Rus was
invaded by the Pechenegs, a nomadic tribe.
They swept through the country and eventually
attacked Kiev.
Olga shut herself up in the city with her
grandsons, Yaropolk, Oleg, and Vladimir.
Now it was her turn to be under siege.
The only chance of survival for the Kievans
was to send a message to a relief force, on
the other side of the river Dnipro.
A clever boy, whose name was never recorded,
volunteered for the sortie.
He could speak the language of the Pechenegs
and so he simply walked out of the city with
a bridle in his hand, asking the nomadic riders
if anybody had seen his horse.
The ruse worked and he was able to jump into
the river and swim to the other shore.
The relief army soon arrived and their general,
called Pretich, convinced the leader of the
Pechenegs that his was just the vanguard of
a massive army led by Vyaroslav.
These Rus were crafty people, indeed, and
all their foes were a bunch of yokels, apparently:
the Pechenegs bought the lie and agreed to
a truce.
In the meanwhile, Olga had sent a messenger
to recall the Prince, who returned in time
to decisively drive the Pechenegs back into
the steppes.
For many years Svyatoslav remained in Kiev,
finally fulfilling his duties of ruler, in
addition to his early honors as a conqueror.
But in 969 he announced to his mother and
his advisors, the boyars, that he had no intention
to remain in Kiev anymore.
During his earlier campaigns, he had established
his base in the city of Pereyaslavets, where
all his riches were concentrated:
" Gold, silks, wine, and various fruits from
Greece, silver and horses from Hungary and
Bohemia, and from Rus furs, wax, honey, and
slaves."
If that was the truth, he had a point.
But Olga was sad to see him depart once again.
Now aged 70, the Princess was in poor health
and begged him first to await her death, and
then go wherever he would like.
The Prince yielded, but he did not have to
wait long.
Three days after Olga had made her plea, she
died.
Her son, her grandsons, and all of her people
wept for her in mourning.
Olga had given command not to hold a funeral
feast for her, as was part of the pagan traditions.
Instead, she had called for a Christian priest
to perform the last rites in a subdued ceremony.
It was her grandson Vladimir the Great who
eventually converted all of the Kievan Rus
to the Orthodox faith, but Olga was hailed
by later generations as Equal among the Apostles,
for her role as a precursor to the widespread
introduction of Christianity.
In the Primary Chronicle, it is written that
she was as the dawn that precedes the day.
“She shone like the moon by night, and she
was radiant among the infidels like a pearl
in the mire.
She was the first from Rus to enter the kingdom
of God, and the sons of Rus thus praise her
as their leader, for since her death she has
interceded with God in their behalf.”
Princess Olga of Kiev was canonized in 1547,
officially becoming Saint Olga.
She is probably the only mass murderering
Saint in history, but I may be wrong.
Other monarchs and Popes have been canonized
over the centuries, and these rulers can rarely
have a career without getting their hands
at least a little bit bloody.
So, I hope you liked today’s video.
As I mentioned at the start, it is difficult
to discern which parts of Olga’s life belong
to the realm of history, and which to the
realm of myth.
What parts do you think were true and what
parts do you believe were medieval propaganda?
Please comment, share and subscribe … and
as usual, thank you for watching!